so hello everybody we are back with
richard rowland for one more episode of
our universal history
uh we've been talking about a lot of
stuff in the past several months some
things that many people have never heard
about strange legends going to the ends
of the earth with our series on ethiopia
but now a lot of people will be excited
because we're finally coming to talk
about the grail i know many people have
been waiting for us to talk about the
grail just because it's such a prominent
figure in in western legends and there's
so much around it even up to today in
popular culture so i'm really happy to
have richard to talk about this because
i know he's going to surprise me as well
with some of his knowledge and so
richard thanks for coming along
i'm super excited to do this uh the
grail is really important to me and i
think it's uh it's one of these great
nexus points in the whole question of
universal history so i think that
i think that uh by the end of
you know probably it's gonna take us
maybe a couple of videos to get through
some of this grail material
um by the by the time we get through
that i think people will have a much
better idea about
let's say sort of the organic way
that universal history kind of develops
and then it's actually kind of this
ongoing process right
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so before we start though i have a
little personal thing going on which is
that richard is one of the uh the the
first people to actually read a copy of
god's dog as many people know
in the at the end of october probably
when this is coming out the crowdfunding
will have already started for our
graphic novel and so i wanted richard to
to say a few things about what he
thought about our graphic novel well
first of all you owe me an afternoon uh
because i i had sat down i was actually
at a coffee shop working and i sat down
i was like all right i got this list of
things like i'm gonna do some writing
and some study and all this different
stuff and then as i'm in the middle of
that you message me and you're like hey
do you want to look at god's dog and i
was like well i guess that's the rest of
my day so um
it's really cool
um
there are
just i mean
just the opening pages there are so many
things in them
which if people have been attentive
long-term uh viewers and listeners of
your podcast
they're going to pick up on probably
instantly but i think the thing that's
really impressive to me is the
way that all of those symbolic elements
like they're not just like
oh here's a neat symbolism thing let's
wedge this end right but they're
actually they are really brought
together in this very cohesive way in
this kind of medieval way of
of relating them relating them to each
other in such a way that we can um
[Music]
we can uh sort of see how these concepts
relate um i think there are probably
very few people
who are going to be uh
really bothered by the by the let's say
the the freedom that you take with with
chronology um i say very few people
because i think that kind of person
probably isn't going to read your your
graphic novel anyway
uh but uh but i also think it's it's
maybe going to be a really great proof
case for how a bunch of the things that
we're talking about in universal history
in hagiography
in uh
you know all these christian legends the
lives of the saints i mean you've got st
george is in there saint christopher is
in there seeing simeon the skylight is
in there um where people who obviously
did not exist people people obviously
didn't didn't didn't ever meet right
yeah um
and uh but they're all sort of in there
together and and uh chris st george is a
really cool character um
we're big st george fans at my at my
house so there's that one
that one sequence that i sent you a
screenshot of and i was like this is
really cool and i had to i'd come and
come home and show that to my son george
who's named after c nice
i didn't know and uh yeah so um i don't
know it's to be really great i i think
this it's going to do a lot of really
important things
one of the the things that it's doing
and i know this is probably one of your
main goals
is to
return
our
what what should be let's say our native
storytelling language
uh and you know that i am obviously a
big tolkien fan i have a whole podcast
right there's no doubt of your there's
no
my talking bona fides should not be in
nothing in question right
but i think part of the reason that
tolkien is so dominant when it comes to
imaginative storytelling especially in
christian spheres to the point that most
of us if we were going to sit down and
write a work of like fantasy fiction or
something i mean tom shippy says you
have to spend the first few years just
writing the tolkien out of your system
right
but part of the reason that he's become
so dominant is precisely that his books
came along at a time
when christians had lost
their
uh
lost their native
storytelling language like we we become
so disconnected from it that the only
option that we really had was to make
something like
middle earth
so i think that um and i'm not saying
that's bad obviously again i don't think
anyone's going to question my love of
tolkien but i do think that it's really
important that we regain
our
uh this regain this this what should be
for christians it should be our native
language right and
the thing is like once you do that once
you get really deep into something
then you go from having you know you
enter into the glorious freedom of the
sons of god right you go from having to
be like
just really rigidly strict
with okay this this chronology and i'm
gonna write this this incredibly you
know like detailed historical novel and
maybe i don't believe these miracles and
gotta question all these things right
you go from that uh approach to instead
being able to because because you
inhabit these things as like a native
speaker of the language you can then
play with it with the kind of freedom
that a native speaker of english has
right a native speaker of english can do
certain things with poetry that somebody
who's learning english as a second
language can't do or wouldn't understand
and i think you've accomplished that in
this graphic novel um and i want to
encourage everyone to please go and back
it um i'm going to be getting multiple
copies uh for gifts i mean christmas is
coming up soon so um i i don't know if
they'll fulfill before probably not
probably not i wish i i didn't i didn't
i didn't promise promise
to be clear but uh but anyway i'm gonna
be uh getting multiple copies as gifts
and i would encourage other people to do
so as well we want this book to do well
so that we can have lots more things
like this so yeah thanks richard i
appreciate it yeah the the goal of this
first uh crowdfunding is to
to kind of generate enough excitement
and uh honestly enough money so that we
can now put these out regularly you know
like every six months or whatever so we
can get the whole story out because this
is just the first chapter it's just the
beginning the story is already totally
written it's it's very big so we need a
lot of room to tell it there's this
great moment at the beginning of the
graphic novel if i could just share a
little bit of it's not really a spoiler
but
um
where there's you know these pilgrims
are walking along and they're singing
this hymn and i read the hymn
and i messaged you and i said which
syrian hymn is that
like
i i couldn't remember which one it was
but it was so obviously syrian you know
that it it seemed uh like it like it had
to be and then you messaged back and
it's oh it's this one
but it was just it was really cool um
yeah so i'm i'm jazzed about it cool
all right now on to the grail so let's
start us off with the grail so what i
wanted to do for this first video on the
grail is to talk about
what we could say the seeds or the
sources are the ground out of which the
grail legends which are primarily
explored through a genre of literature
called a romance not
not like
you know people falling in love married
hopefully the people who watch your show
are like astute enough to know what what
that term means right uh a romance
basically just means like a high
adventure story right yeah because we've
been talking about the alexander romance
and so i'm sure they write it wasn't a
love story right right right yes um now
actually people you know do actually
fall in love and get married in these
stories but they're not just about that
so
okay
so i want to talk about three sources
and the first will be what i'll call the
celtic
reliquary tradition so those of you who
are wanting like the symbolism of
ireland and things like that you're not
going to quite get that in this video
but you are going to get some of it
the second thing i want to talk about is
the i uh let's call her the iberian
virgin and her grail
and then finally i want to end on joseph
joseph of arimathea
who is of course very important to the
grey of legends and the his links to the
byzantine mystical tradition and sort of
how all that comes in so we're not going
to actually talk about the romances
themselves today and uh i think the
reason for that will be sort of more
apparent when we get to the end so
to begin with
uh
in the celtic tradition
the
the way that
celtic christianity thought about and
treated relics is a little bit different
from what maybe you know other
traditions have done so
in the celtic tradition it's the uh
there's a great deal of veneration given
to the relics of the saints this is
nothing unusual in christianity what's
unusual is that these relics don't
always mean bones in fact they usually
don't mean the bones of a saint uh they
usually seem to mean uh items that the
relic that the saint has left behind
them
liturgical books gospels
uh croziers uh bells
chalices etc
and there
if you read celtic hagiography and i've
been reading quite a lot of it lately
what you're going to find is a very
unique
honor and and reverence that are given
to these to these items that's different
from what you find in the rest of
christianity um and there's some
scholars who think that these this is
like a let's say a sanctification of the
idea of the
of the tribal palladium you know like
the the relics of or the idols of the
tribe or whatever that are sort of
passed down
in celtic culture that may or may not be
the case if it is the case it's not a
problem for us
right yeah but it's also there in in
scripture in terms of the the passing of
the skins of elijah to elisha and then
there's also the ark itself which is
this this kind of physical object which
isn't uh which isn't the body of the
saint but which
let's say gathers together a certain
amount of authority or power with it uh
right
right and that's the thing to remember
that's odd to this idea of this epidemic
transmitted you know all this stuff yeah
yeah that's the thing to remember about
the ark is that it's a um it's a
container it held the you know the
tables of the law and the the the mana
and aaron's rod that bought it and
goliath sword
weirdly enough right
um so that's
or at least at the very least they kept
goliath sword in the tabernacle right
when david shows up there to get some
food he needs food and a weapon and they
said well the only food we have here is
the showbread
and the only weapon we have here is
goliath sword so they had taken the
sword of this nephilim and they had
actually kept it in the holy place in
the in the tabernacle so that's
yeah that's another video for another
day but um
all right so the the flaming sword
symbolism i know i know i know
so um
i'm sorry all right so the next one okay
so the gaelic so basically this this
gaelic tradition of the importance of
objects which are transmitted and which
are can be connected to a saint so right
and so for instance you had things like
the book of saint columba uh which was
supposed to be which was born they
carried it out in battle
which is not unusual for relics in the
middle ages but the belief was that if a
person who was pure of heart carried the
book
then uh then it would bring victory for
the clan of course there are other
relics that give oracles one of the most
important kinds of relics in the celtic
tradition is a bell which is actually
one of the forms that the grail takes
we'll talk about that later probably
um the bell and of course what are bells
used for in in western liturgy they're
used uh
uh at the the moment of the sacrifice
right at the moment of
of uh the consecration of the gifts
that's you know a belt there's a bell
it's called the sacrifice that is wrong
they still do this in like some
traditional western uh western liturgies
um so bells are very important um
and the idea was you know and and the
the miracles that are attributed to the
to these relics you know they're they're
oracles there's uh you know bells that
refuse to ring in the hand except
of the person for you know to whom it
belongs you know like the saint you know
so how do you know like is this saint
legit or not right is he really the one
who's supposed to be our bishop well the
bell rings for him and not for anyone
else
um
there's um um you know there's a another
bell that actually like sails through
the air from jerusalem to wales right as
a gift from heaven to this particular
bishop
uh
some of the other items are really
really interesting for instance
one of the one of the most common uh
forms that we find in welsh and irish
hagiography
is the idea of a of an altar right and
you we don't typically think of an altar
as being a relic because we think of an
altar as being like you know it's large
it's unwieldy and it's more or less
fixed to a certain place right yeah
but in the celtic tradition they're all
of these floating altars flying altars
right and i think this is somehow
connected to the
the
the the interconnectedness of like uh
so so the the the ancient irish thought
of of let's say mist of course there's a
lot of mist in that part of the world
right they thought it was still sort of
being part of heaven and so there was
this idea that heaven and earth kind of
became like
were a little more permeable at certain
places right and so the this this idea
of the floating alder floating altar
seems to be connected to this so one
that's actually really important to the
grail legend is the altar that was given
to saint david of wales this is you know
the patron saint of wales um
and the story uh about him is that
uh his uh his birth was foretold to his
father by an angel in a dream
and uh his father was supposed to go out
hunting when he was going to find three
things he was going to find a stag a
fish and a honeycomb
and these each of these items are are
some somehow foretelling or or prophetic
of saint david's ministry so for
instance
um this the angel says that as the honey
is in the wax so he that is david will
hold a spiritual sense
in a historical instrument uh which i
just mentioned here because i think
that's a great way to sort of describe
symbolism
or way to describe universal history
where you have these these patterns that
are above the historical but now they're
manifesting in historical ways
that was supposed to be what the life of
the saint is
but there's also this this fish
right and this fish on which he was
supposed to be fed
now
i think most people know that the fish
is an ancient symbol for christianity
what people sometimes don't realize
especially like down here in texas
pretty much every other car has like a
bump it has a little fish bumper sticker
on it uh what most of the people who
have those bumper stickers don't
probably understand is it's not just
that the fish is a symbol for
christianity but it's specifically a
eucharistic it's a symbol of the
eucharist right right so you've got all
these you know evangelicals god bless
them driving around with the symbol of
the eucharist on the back of their uh
yeah because it's the fish giving in a
way it's like the gift because the fish
is leaving itself to be eaten yes that's
the mystery he's like that's why like or
else why would you have a fish as a
symbol for christianity and it's also
like the treasure that's drawn up out of
death yes there's that as well
all these different things right uh
there's another saint that's really
wonderful uh his name is elar which is
the same name as hillary but it's not
hillary or poitier it's a different
illar
and ilar
was just found he was a foundling it was
found on the stone in the middle of a
river so they they took him and they
came the monks that found them took him
they came back the next day and on that
stone in the middle of the river there
was just a fish
so they took that and they fed the child
with the fish and they came back every
day and every day for the for his whole
childhood there was a fish and that's
what they fed him with and then he grew
up to be this you know awesome wonder
working saint and he could talk to
animals and all this stuff right um i
mean i loved i love all the best stuff
of comics i just love this stuff just
enormously right
um and so uh of course uh the
the um
they're we're talking about the floating
altars right
yeah so i'm just mentioning the fish
thing because the fish and the floating
altars seem to be connected and uh
there's of course this really important
figure in the later grail stories the
rich fisherman or the fisher king right
who's going to become really important
to the story of the grail so just sort
of like
you know put a pin in that i'm
interested to hear your opinion on that
because as a french person i always see
it as the sinner king like that's how i
see it but oh interesting yeah we can
talk about that yeah
um
so in the yeah so the earliest romantics
we see the ancestor of the grail keepers
is uh he's made to catch this miraculous
fish and that's what gives him this
title that's that's passed down uh and
yeah we can talk a little bit more about
that but i want to note it just note
here that among welsh saints and among
celtic saints
this this idea uh this there's a
connection to fishing into fish that
okay seems to crop up over and over
again now i mention all of this because
the possession
of these relics of the saints altars
bales uh bells
chalices croziers gospel books etc
the possession of these relics is a
really important theme so especially in
welsh christianity um so you know when
when cod waller is sort of like the last
great welsh king when he dies in battle
um it's it's prophesied that he will
return obviously this is what happens
right uh is prophesied that he will
return when
all of the ancient relics of the welsh
church are are revealed when they're
uncovered when they manifest again so
it's like
it's like um
um and and the idea is it's not that
we've totally lost them it's but they're
in hiding right now
and they're they're you know so there's
this idea that you have these families
you know very much like what's going on
with the ark in ethiopia okay but but
obviously more obscure
there's this idea that you have this
this handed down tradition of the relics
of one saint to somebody in their
lineage
and that the the person who has
inherited them also inherits you know
like that cloak of elijah that you
mentioned um also inherits some degree
of their grace yeah
so i mention all of this to say that in
the celtic tradition and this is picked
up in one of the later romances called
the high history of the holy grail the
grail doesn't have
one form
the grail has five forms
and it is strongly implied
that these forms at least one of these
forms is a bell a sacrificing bell
we're not told what all of the forms are
though and the reason we're not told
what all the forms are i'll read this
again in our next video the reason we're
not told what all of the forms are is
that it says
it's not good to speak too explicitly of
the sacraments so when arthur goes into
the chapel of the grail and he actually
sees the grail in this particular
version of the story
he sees it in the context of the mass of
the liturgy
and
the five forms of the grail are revealed
to him and we're told the final form is
the chalice but we're not told what the
other four are but again there's a
strong implication that at least one of
them is the bell is it bell no
interesting i want to say something a
little bit about the idea of the relic
and the power just to just because one
of the things you mentioned i think it's
important for people to see the
connection is that when you believe in a
world where symbolism
happens let's say there's a sense in
which you talked about how if someone
carries the book of saying columba
and has a pure heart
then the relic will be effective that is
the relic will become a vehicle you know
a connection between the two and so
there's a sense in which
this is something which i think would
have been implicitly understood
in the the different legends of these
relics and goes into the grill which is
that the only knight that can find the
grail that can reach the grail has to
have a pure heart so there's there's
actually a notion with the fact that you
receive it is almost like a proof that
you're
right of pure heart right there's a
connection where just because you have a
pure heart you have access to this but
then having it becomes a proof of the
fact that you also have a pure heart and
so there's a there's a incarnational way
of seeing the world where it's not like
there isn't this arbitrary capacity i
say this because
just because i was telling i was telling
richard recently that i just before that
i watched the movie constantine again
where you have this arbitrary idea that
if you can get this relic you know if
you can get this object then you're
gonna have a certain power that you can
then use and it's almost like uh it's
almost like finding a grenade or finding
a bomb it's completely arbitrary it has
nothing to do with virtue it's like
harry potter style magic where you just
have to like technically be proficient
and learn these spells in the right way
and and know how to use these things
almost like mechanical tools but that is
not
the way in which ancient people thought
there was a deep connection between a
virtue and let's say the power that the
objects could have and also kind of
christian faith and all of this and the
manner in which objects could manifest
or have power in the world
so
all of this
so so all of this it's important to
remember because the relic is always a
it's not just that the
that the relic has like the powers of
the virtues of the saint right uh that
this is god's power right it's god's
grace
we say his you know like his energies
it's something that's constantly given
to uh to us
as a gift
right and so yeah it's not this
mechanical thing and that's part of why
we have to be really careful about how
we talk about this stuff and that's why
there would be a certain amount of
secrecy
about
um
you know even just like a saint whose
relics we have
right we don't parade them around the
streets you know just you know for the
you know
exposing the mystery right at the very
least we're gonna have it in the name of
the church
some relics or you know especially holy
icons things like this
we might bring out on certain feast days
right uh uh there would be a time when
the mystery is revealed but we don't you
know again yeah it's not this mechanical
thing i was literally just arguing with
somebody about that on discord before
this video started um i i said every
time you say the word magical system a
fairy dies you know it's
i i can't i i really i cannot stand
systematized magic in in fantasy fiction
yeah so
um i wanna i wanna mention one thing um
because this will be really important
for talking about the grail later on but
also you're gonna get just a tremendous
kick out of it being who you are okay so
saint david
is given this altar
right uh and so this happens when he is
on um
he is on his pilgrimage to jerusalem uh
that he is uh we're told that as god
gave matthias
in judea christ in jerusalem and peter
in rome so he has given saint david to
be in the island of britain so the is
the idea that st david was sort of like
the
the the keeper of like the apostolic
lineage in the island of britain
and uh there's this is a long time like
before the joseph of arimathea stuff and
all this right
um
and we're told that the the patriarch of
jerusalem who's the one
consecrating david as bishop
gives him
one of these altars
it says a certain hallowed altar
in which the lord's body had reposed
and this seems to be connected to that
stone there's that stone in the the
church of the holy sepulchre i can't
remember the name right now
um
we can probably put a picture of it up
here but
that stone on which christ's body was
laid after he was brought down off the
cross and that whole all the legends and
the stories surrounding what happens to
christ's body when it's brought down off
the cross are going to be essential to
understanding where the grail comes from
so we're told that he's given this
hallowed altar in which the lord's body
had proposed
which abounded in innumerable virtues
and then we're told never was this altar
seen
after the death of the bishop saint
david by any son of man but it lies
hidden
covered with skins
what i know right strange legend yeah
and so uh and so and it says hence
the common people call it the gift from
heaven
so as we talk about the uh i just i knew
you would love the fact that it's
covered in skin yeah what else would you
cover it in
um
but uh uh there's also another uh uh
saint um actually in in the same book
um
uh saint karanak to whom we're told that
christ gave an honorable altar from
heaven the color of which no person can
comprehend but this altar is also
wrapped in skins most of the time so
it's like this jeweled altar that's like
a color that no one on earth has ever
seen but it's it's kept veiled right um
so i'm gonna mention i mentioned this
because
the key idea of the grail isn't really
just a chalice right obviously
that that becomes the most enduring
image for kind of obvious reasons in
some senses it's because it's the best
image right
but
the idea of the grail is really
something
which is hidden
which contains or has contained the body
and the blood of christ
right so there's this altar which had
somehow contained the lord's body
we're not it's not it's not elaborated
on because it's in jerusalem there does
seem to be a connection to this this
stone on which christ's body was laid
um
and keep in mind that most of the grail
legends start popping up in western
europe after the during the time of the
crusades so people are coming from the
east and they're bringing back these
these tales of like amazing relics that
they've seen or like heard legends about
uh but that's the key idea of the grail
so we're told for instance um
like i mentioned the height history of
the grail of the grill has these five
forms
only the last of which is the chalice
it's it's going to be much later we'll
talk about this in our next video uh
when robert de boron
um
he has the grail become the cup of the
last supper right but that's sort of the
final form you could say that's the
final form that the grill takes in the
romances like once it takes that form
the grail is always that in all the
future retellings yeah for sure because
it's not clear that that's what's going
on right when you see it's not that idea
is not at all there in court for sure a
vessel
it's it's for sure eucharistic vessel
yeah that's it that's it um and we'll
talk more about where that connection
comes in in a little bit
um
so you have
um so you you have this idea of like the
the altar which is kind of like the
ultimate version of this in the celtic
tradition this hidden altar that comes
from heaven that's contained god's body
and which is now covered over it's
veiled it's covered in these garments of
skin okay
so that's the that's kind of the first
thread in in what eventually becomes the
grail story uh the second one we could
talk about is in the um
what i've called the iberian virgin and
her grail and if you want to know more
about this by the way i know people love
like where can i go read about this
myself there's this great book called
the virgin of the grail by joffer joseph
gehring
and uh it's it's all about
this image so the image that you see uh
manifesting
in let's say in the pyrenees right
around the time of between the third and
the fourth and a little bit after the
fourth crusade
right you have these images that come up
over and over again these beautiful
romanesque frescoes i mean they're
really stunning um whenever somebody's
like i'd like to see more western art in
churches or something like that i'm like
well i would too but i don't think we
mean the same thing by that i think you
mean like renaissance stuff and i mean
this stuff like this is this is like
amazing amazing stuff and very like it's
very sort of distinctly western but also
really consonant with a byzantine
tradition and so the first image of this
uh seems to be and this isn't a it's by
an anonymous painter fresco
do you call somebody who paints frescoes
like a painter or they are a yeah i
don't know anyway
um uh he's called the master of saint
clement because we don't know who he was
people didn't sign their work
and uh but he was a really gifted
iconographer
and in the apes of this church the saint
clement of uh saint clements in uh of
tol in in the pyrenees mountains you
have this image of christ and glory
surrounded by the the four creatures and
i mean it's very very byzantine image
if you've ever been to an orthodox
church you've seen this somewhere you'll
immediately recognize it but then
beneath him
around the the you know around the base
of the of the apps of the church you see
the choir of the apostles right so the
12 apostles plus plus some
but then in their in their center and
sort of standing as like the first among
equals among them is the mother of god
and the mother of god is standing there
and she's holding you can kind of see it
in the cover art right here because this
is holding a cup of something he's
holding it it's a dish it's a dish yeah
so the word grail means um
it means like a large uh shallow serving
dish and actually specifically
specifically it's a serving dish for
serving fish that's what you serve in a
grill and this is in christianity it
says the virgin he sees this version
coming in holding this large grail uh in
which you might serve like a pike or a
lamprey in other words like a very large
fish
so again thinking about fish here um
it's carrying right this idea of a
container for food a container for fish
right an altar or an altar or like a
tombstone
all of these images of of these
containers but that are also um
yeah that are also secret that are
heavenly all of this is kind of coming
together right
so there's something there's something
about this and and this um
this original image seems to be ugly of
the ascension i should have prefaced
that by saying this original image seems
to have been of the ascension so in the
byzantine tradition right when we
portray the ascension it's essentially
exactly like this we show christ in
glory he's being taken up to heaven on
the like the terubic throne and then
beneath him we have all of the apostles
and in the midst of the apostles we have
the mother of god and she's flanked on
either side right by two angels you've
done some really great videos it's been
a while but you've done some really
great videos about this icon of the
ascension right which is an icon of the
church
what the church was at that moment what
it is now and
and of course the way that we expect
yeah and it's it's an eschatological
vision as well it's also right how
because it says even in scripture that
that christ will return in the same
manner that he that he left
so this seems to be a
uh a reworking of the byzantine image of
the ascension uh but what's different
about it and this is the crucial
difference and this is about 50 years
before kretion wrote his
his grail story which is the first real
grail romance right
um so 50 years before that this guy
painted this image and he shows the
virgin mary holding in her hand this
grail and in the grail there are flames
shooting up out of it
so it's not totally sure what's in the
grail the author of this book has some
theories i don't think they're all like
totally right because there's some
things i mean he's he's writing about
christian ritual from like an outsider
perspective whereas anybody who's like
you know lived in the church and and
been to been to liturgy enough times and
things like this uh they're but but on
the whole
um i think he's right in that he says
that the contents of the bowl are either
you know it's either the eucharist
or it's
chrism
um
and that
for our purposes it doesn't really
matter which one of those it is right
that that in other words like this this
this fiery bowl
right
um contains
uh let's say it it shows the way in
which the grace of the holy spirit has
been given to the church which the the
the the creator of this fresco saw as
being
mediated through the incarnational
experience of the church which
which we understand through the the
mother of god so he so would he so this
author does he see this as a kind of
small image of pentecost yes wow
he doesn't talk about pentecost so much
you just talk about it a little bit
again that's where i think
you know because in the western
tradition by the way the image of the
image of pentecost resembles the image
of ascension
right we have this image where we don't
show we don't have a character in the
center and it's like uh
it's like these these chairs going
around like this in the door but the
western version and the one in the
raboula gospels which is like some one
of the earliest versions of the
of pentecost we see that disciples in a
line with the mother of god in the
center and then the fire coming down
upon them all so like it's it's more
it's closer to the image of the
ascension that you would find that you
would find uh
normally i didn't know that i didn't
know that uh in armenian depictions of
the ascension is very often the same so
that you know where you do have the
mother of god there and i actually have
seen some byzantine icons that have her
there not the one that's in our church
but uh
like my home parish but i have seen that
a few times so yeah it's a very old
tradition people say people don't like
it because it's not the one we ended up
with but yeah the idea it's a very very
old tradition to have the mother god in
the center
so it's i mean this is a little aside
but uh once my daughter for an art class
decided that she wanted to do an icon of
the of pentecost and she was just doing
it like totally from memory having grown
up in the church and things and she just
even though that the fresco that we have
on the ceiling of our church uh it's
like right on right on the other side of
the apes on the uh on the other side of
the auction is from the apes we have a
very traditional pentecost icon nobody's
seated in the middle and that's the
that's as you know that's the icon that
she's seen in her entire growing up but
when she did the icon she put the mother
of god right in the middle like it was
just like a normal you know here's mary
here's baby jesus here's the church
around them and like yeah so that's it's
i i j she's like oh that's huh that's
really interesting
um if anybody's interested by the way i
wrote an article specifically about that
on the two women on the two images of
the church uh let's say the
the the the church of the jews the
church the gentiles or the inner woman
and the outer woman and so how it's
related to
to pentecost to ascension and pentecost
so i'll put a link of that in the
description yeah that'd be great
so uh right after this image what we
have what we see then happening in these
in churches all across let's say this
the certain region of spain
is uh
and and then into into france we see we
see this image of and it very quickly
changes into just mary holding a chalice
but we show this image popping up in
romanesque iconography from the century
again and again and again
and it's worth noting
that the
the the romancers who
wrote down their versions of the grail
stories right that their patrons their
original patrons were these troubadour
crusader kings and lords who originally
came from this region
right so that so that they're coming
east they're going east for the crusades
they're coming back this iconography
pops up and then about 50 years 50 to
100 years later that's when all the
grail romances start showing up in
western europe so i i find this very
interesting of course it is in in catian
it is
the virg it is a virgin maybe not the
virgin but it is a virgin
who is carrying the grail in the
procession in the in the fisher king's
palace okay
so
the third seed of the grail story and
this is where things
get a little weird
um the third uh seed don't think playing
altars is weird enough i mean we need
much weirdest i mean yeah
okay so we have this uh we have this
icon
of uh you know this is some we call it
like the holy mendelian or the icon made
without hands right if you've been to an
orthodox church you've probably seen
this icon right it's it's it's weird
because it's like an icon
of a towel
with the face of jesus on it right and
this goes back to this legend of of uh
uh which is
let's say attested in some of our
earliest christian historical sources
right uh so much so that you know i i
mean i i personally
i mean it's a feast of the church i take
for granted that it's a it's a real
thing that happened right i have no
reason to doubt doubt it right
um
uh but this legend that essentially
there was uh king abgar of odessa right
who had desired an icon of christ and so
he sent his his people to uh to make a
copy of christ's face like to make a
picture of him
a painting right or to get something of
christ and you know avgar is sick and in
some versions of the story you stick
with leprosy but actually very
importantly
in other versions of the story
especially in the middle ages as the the
legend gets sort of elaborated
he's paralyzed
in other words of course paralysis is
also always sort of
associated with let's say infertility
and all these things right so you have a
paralyzed king
a wounded king
right
uh and and so he sends for something of
the lord's which will which will be able
to heal him
and
uh basically what happens when the um
when the
the people they come to draw christ is
that they can't do it
um like they're actually not able to to
to depict him they can't get his image
and actually in one of the remember what
i said about the grail having five forms
right
in one of the versions of the story in
the middle ages the reason they can't
get his image is because as they start
trying to draw him his image constantly
changes and it goes from being a little
child
to being a 30 year old man to being
christ in his passion to being the
ancient of days right and it moves
through these like
all these different things right and
they can't do it so finally christ
basically makes them an icon
um and uh it's it's at least of his face
but possibly of his entire body yeah so
he imprints his his form onto the claw
right and so he gives that
uh to them and they take it back to the
city of odessa
and
um
there are all kinds of this is people
don't understand now um like we
understand a little bit in in like the
orthodox church because like again we we
have this icon in a lot of places and we
do have a feast for it it's one of the
three feasts of the lord in the month of
august
but
this is a big deal in the middle ages
people copied and re-copied and copied
and re-copied the story many of the
crusaders
who
um uh
obviously odessa was was taken by the
western crusaders and during the first
crusade it was retaken and then uh in
the fourth crusade of course
constantinople was sacked
um
by the time of the fourth crusade the
the icon of the the holy face the holy
mendelian was in constantinople uh at
blackhair and i
and
if you go back and you read
the
uh
the
first hand eyewitness accounts of the
people who saw this icon
but then you also if you read the the
legend so so there were there were
legends that got copied into latin from
a pretty early date that a lot of these
crusaders brought back west with them
and you start looking at
let's say the
the um
the theological connection
between
or
another theological connection but you
start looking at the connection between
uh
the
what the things that are supposed to
happen in the grail chapel or in the
grail palace right or the grail castle
if you look at those and you look at the
rituals that were associated with the
veneration of this icon
in odessa and then in constantinople
later they map
very tightly
okay
and um and of course there's a lot of
other stuff obviously the spear isn't
you know the holy spirit the lance of
longinus uh whose feast day was in the
in the orthodox church was just a few
days ago by the way from when we were
recording this um
uh that that comes up during the time of
the crusades right because it's
uncovered uh or it's believed to be
uncovered during the siege of antioch
and all this other stuff is going on
right so all of the stuff is kind of
coming west and in particular
um we're they're they're
and i don't totally understand uh
because obviously there's the you have
basically like three versions of this
idea of like a cloth that has christ's
face on it right you have the shroud of
turin or the burial shroud you have the
uh like the cloth that st veronica
um is supposed to have pressed against
christ's face came away with an
impression of the icon and then you have
this the holy mandelian the icon made
without hands but in a lot of these
earlier stories those all basically seem
to be the same thing
well for sure they all seem to at least
the the one the earliest one is the is
the mendelian tradition yes okay that's
that's very old so this is this is where
it gets a little
kind of mind-blowing um and i don't even
know how much i want to say about this
but
in in in the early in the earliest
descriptions that we have of people who
went to venerate the mendelian and wrote
about us these are firsthand eyewitness
accounts
it's not just the face okay um that it's
actually a cloth that has been folded
but if you unfold the entire thing it
would give you this impression of
christ's body at least from like the
waist up
um and that it was
um
and that that this impression was made
with christ's sweat and with his blood
so it's more like the
the the turin the shroud yeah yeah so
but typically speaking what they would
do is that this whole thing would be
folded up in fact one of the names for
the cloth
means like they ate
the cloth that's been folded eight times
or something like this and they would
fold the cloth up
and then they would so that only the
face could be seen and you could only
see that see the face i mean it's just
it's heavily protected so you could only
see the face if you look through a
certain aperture which you're only
allowed to do at sort of certain times
right and so so it's it's
it's uh
again it's this idea of here's something
that that um
that contains christ's body that
contains christ's blood right or at
least the impression of them yeah well
it did i mean it's it's like
just right right just like yeah right
and so all of this is
all of this is um tied then
with the the byzantine apocryphal
tradition surrounding joseph of
arimathea
so um joseph of arimathea who was put
into prison um uh
and released after the emperor of
vespasian was healed by the holy cloth
of leprosy um he's um
you know this is the this is the legend
that's found in the
there's a there's a
uh the gospel of nicodemus and the acts
of pilate these two apocryphal
works that are really important in our
tradition yeah when i say they're
apocryphal i don't mean that we totally
discount them i think maybe by now
people know that but um that is that
source of the uh
sorry the source of the anastasia's icon
is from the god right exactly exactly
yeah so so obviously a really important
part of our of our tradition
um
uh so joseph
jose yeah so joseph
takes the the blood or he he takes the
cup or he
carries it so he's closely associated
originally with his burial cloth
especially in the in the rituals
surrounding its veneration at odessa or
burial cloth or the mendelian or
whatever you want to call it he's very
closely associated with that in the
tradition of the city of odessa
now
the other place where this comes in
would be two two things
one is that
uh during the first especially the first
millennia of the church going into like
the 13th and 14th century there's a
really rich tradition
of byzantine
you know eastern christian mystical
commentaries on the liturgy right uh you
could basically say it's like doing
allegorical commentary on the liturgy
except that nobody knows what allegory
means anymore and so i don't like to use
it that word because people get confused
but it's just it's ways of of sort of
let's say interpreting and explicating
the mystery of of the divine liturgy of
course the most most important one of
these is probably saint maximus the
confessor's mystical uh ecclesial
mystagogy which i've talked about a lot
and i'm a big fan of that particular
work
one of the things i love about it is
that i only understand maybe like a
fourth of it um because because he's
like the liturgy has these four or five
senses and he re explains the first
sense and i'm like okay i get that he
explains the second sentence and i'm
like okay i get that and then he starts
explaining like the third fourth fifth
census and i'm like
i don't i can't i don't even know what
the subject is i don't even can't even
yeah right like i don't even like my my
i'm such a baby you know spiritually
like i have no idea what that's even
about right yeah exactly but um
um
so in
the
in these commentaries okay
uh and uh
uh
i'm just gonna pull up my notes here
because because there's like a whole
chain of custody for this information
uh but basically in these commentaries
what we get is uh this idea so you find
this in like uh saint germainis uh uh
commentary this idea that
there is a
let's say like a polyvalence or an
overlapping sense of meaning
between
the the chalice or the patents
the
um
the
what's it called the epitaphion you know
like that like the the cloth that has
which is exactly
which is an image of the shroud
basically right the image that has the
body of christ uh stitched or painted on
it and that which is on the altar right
so between that between the the patents
and the and actually
the the the epitaphian seems to have
developed and i'm sure there are people
out there who know way more about
liturgical history than i do but it
seems to have developed originally from
the veil which is placed over the
chalice and over the patents so this
seemed to be related which you know okay
all intuitively like on a symbolic level
all that stuff makes sense right yeah
but then you have the then you have the
um
uh so so there's a relationship between
these things and then the deacon who
carries them out during the liturgy
right and such that we are told and this
is in the byzantine liturgical
commentary which is then translated into
latin which then is like re
reworked into another latin commentary
on the latin mass and like there's three
or four levels of this versions of this
that come to the west right about all
the time right about the time that all
the grail legends are popping up in
which we are told
that the deacon at this moment is
imaging the role of joseph of arimathea
really
so
this stuff is like deeply and of course
i mean
in in um
well i mean i guess because he carried
you could say it really immediately
because he carried the body right down
and he put the body in a tomb and think
about it right think about how
heavily
joseph of arimathea features in the
eastern liturgy right that long
beautiful the noble joseph jamari that
we sing every year we sing it during
holy week we sing it again on the sunday
of the myrrh bearers right um this
you know so this this the the role that
he had in taking the body of christ down
and sort of carrying it he's he's so
closely connected in the eastern
liturgical tradition um not just in like
the byzantine version that's come down
to to us in our church but also like in
the syrian tradition he's so closely
connected to the act of carrying the
body of christ that that's the
connection
that these these liturgical like these
mystical commentaries on the mass and on
the divine liturgy that's the connection
that they make yeah because also joseph
offers the vessel
yes he actually offers the tomb like he
pays for it right he he buys the tomb
and so he offers this vessel for the
body and so it's like it yeah it all
makes sense like very in a very
immediate way notwithstanding all the
legends which are going to come later
right so the legends
about like joseph coming to england and
all this stuff that comes much later
okay
comes much later right um they make so
much sense like with all this symbolism
right we know where what england is
right so that's the thing though um is
is uh one of the things i want to point
to with with something like the grail
legends
where you have
where you have a clear a story that is
clearly non-historical let's say
um but also
so fundamentally true that we keep
trying to tell it over and over again
right like the holy grail as far as i'm
concerned
the holy grail is like the great story
of western civilization like it's the
big problem
right the fact that the fact that in the
early stories of the grail
i'll talk more about this in the next
video but in the early stories of the
veil the grail the the grail quest is
achieved but the more we retell it and
the longer it goes the more unattainable
the grail becomes
okay i think that's
i think that's uh
really
really um
telling yeah
so yeah but it's also it also has to do
like if you unders understand what's
going on when the grey legends are
appearing and you notice that
you know
there is the idea that there is a
mystery which is no longer accessible
to me this is something that especially
as a as a as someone as an orthodox
person i can see as related to the one
of the problems which comes in the late
middle ages as this nominalism gets set
in as certain branches of so it's almost
as if mythically there's an intuition
that there's something off and that
there's something that we used to have
access to or that we should have access
to that we could we don't anymore like
there's an aspect of the mystery which
has been kind of that has been kind of
pulled away from us and uh and and so
there's
there's i think there's it's related to
the schism i i think so yeah so so this
is where i'm gonna get into get myself
into a little bit you shouldn't say
these things so that i can be the one
that get i i i can be the one that gets
in trouble with some of your listeners
okay
um but a lot okay but but there are a
lot of serious grail scholars out there
who have pointed out the fact that the
grail legend
begins to arrive in western europe
exactly at the time that people start
arguing about transubstantiation
right right at the time that berengarias
and all these people they're like
they're like is it a symbol is it what
is it this is it that right just right
at the point that of course that's where
somebody like alexander schmemann sort
of points the original that's where
maybe things start to go wrong you know
everyone's got maybe their date for when
things start to go wrong but what
everybody agrees with on is that
something obviously went wrong right um
but but right at the time
that
the the secularism begins to be born and
that that rift uh in in western
sacramento theology starts to slowly
widen in what's eventually going to
become the reformation and all the
things that kind of are downstream from
that
right at the time that was happening is
when the grail story starts to manifest
itself in western europe
and that culminates the the idea the
unattainable grail
culminates right around the time of the
fourth crusade which is kind of the
death knell
in in any hopes of reunion between the
eastern and western church
um
you know
i think you know
my reading and i think a lot of i think
there's a lot of evidence for this is
that historically people still thought
they were going to be able to get the
band back together yeah right until
you know latin crusaders sacrifice
and they put a prostitute on the throne
of the patriarch of constantinople in
the church of agyo sophia and at that
point
they were like
this is not happening
maybe maybe like you know uh
you know maybe maybe this is not gonna
work out after yeah right
so
and i and i think you're right like i
think it's connected to those things and
it's part of what makes the story of the
grail so important
and also so tragically painful
um and when i what i want to do in the
next video is is to start going through
some of the romances of the grail yeah
and i want to start with christian
because even though his version is not
let's say the definitive version i think
in some ways it's still the best yeah um
and i think that um actually people have
been reading it profoundly wrong for a
very long time
that everyone thinks it's unfinished and
everyone thinks percival doesn't get the
grail and i think that's totally wrong
oh right wow yeah so just tease that for
next video so so maybe so what i my last
words are going to be something like
even now in the discussion that we've
had talking about the sources of where
the grey legend comes
from we notice that there is something
about the grail itself which is related
to the west that has to do with the west
if we understand the west in the sense
of the place where the sun sets
that that western edge of the world and
we always have to remember now we live
in america and so
this has kind of been thrown up there's
been a stretching out of the west you
could say but for the ancients britain
was the edge of the world right it was
it was
represented that eastern that western
edge of reality where the barbarians
were still there and it was still kind
of a wild land that had to be tamed you
know we remember that the giants were
there there's all these these these
stories about what it is that britain
represents so there's a sense in which
all these stories are kind of coming
together and manifesting the west
and manifesting this notion of the
container
and the support for something sacred
something which holds the sacred in it
the altar this cha the the cup the
chalice the grail the the the cloth all
of these are all these supports and it's
also a book there's also a version of
the grail mid-ledge which it's a book so
it's all these idea of the of the
support
of of something from above right
and so it is of course related to the
feminine
and so we can already see that why
so much of the madness of the grail
stories that have come to us recently
and dan brown i'm talking to you in this
this this this statement is they wanted
to make it about right they all wanted
to make it about the feminine and
they're totally right that it is about
this about the feminine uh but we also
need to understand it rather as
something which is pointing beyond the
kind of crass
the crass way in which people like dan
brown have wanted to bring about like as
if all these mysteries all these stories
what they're pointing to
is some historical fact that everybody
wants to hide and that's it there's no
more meaning to it than that it's all
about hiding something that happened
that nobody wants you to find out about
yeah and so that's really like if it was
that then she just all throw it in the
trash anyways because it's not it's not
really interesting
so i think that i think that the things
you're saying are
so something that's really curious to me
about this grail stuff right is that
essentially
all of the pieces are there in the east
but the east never has a grail story
they never have a grail legend they
never have a grail romance and in
general the east never
it they they just never develop
let's say imaginative literature
to the same degree even like you know
like the great
orthodox novels like dostoyevsky or
something like that are
you know they're like you know uh
super super like like in your face and
very like grounded and gritty and
realistic and things like this and it's
not that we don't have like wonder tales
or or things but when we have them we
they tend to be in hagiography or in
stories of miracles and things like this
and there's like a
like just this experience of a much more
proximate experience of the divine
um of the miraculous of relics of saints
of angels of all these different things
that is there initially in say like the
age of the saints like the fifth and
sixth century you know whales or
somewhere like that but tends to starts
to be lost in the west
and as that
distance begins to stretch out you have
something very much like
and this is this is
i mean this is something i've been
thinking about a lot because i write
fiction obviously i love talking about
fiction right
fiction is the garment of skins in which
saint david's altar is wrapped
right it's it's our inability
to
to come to some of these things in like
a really bald way in like a really open
way
um we can't do it anymore
and i say i say this you know as a
obviously i'm a practicing christian i'm
a member of the orthodox church but i'm
also a western person yeah and that that
hasn't changed and i'm like i'm totally
uh
as much as i can be i try to be aware of
what that means and what you know
obviously there's some great things
about that there's also some some big
limitations that i'm trying to work
through
and i think that uh i think that you
could say the grail romances right and
the way that they develop
they develop precisely at this time that
something is being lost
that there's a rift that's happening
and they become a way to
take that thing that's being lost and
sort of wrap it in this protective
covering of skins which becomes poetry
and romance and all this stuff and a
sense of nostalgia there's a sense in
the grail of nostalgia yeah especially
the later especially the later version
like robert de berlin this this deep
sense that
man if we could have if we could have i
mean this is all the way back in in
krita and like in his his romance which
is the first real romance like that
sense that if he could have asked the
right question he could have asked
what's the grant
yeah if you could have asked the right
question
then he would like then the land would
have been healed yeah you know that that
in other words communion would have been
restored which i think actually again
happens in that romance and people miss
it so we'll we'll talk about it all
right well that'll be that'll be the way
to end this to see
how is it that richard thinks that that
that the kids ain't got it right well i
love kids romance and so i'm really
excited to find out about it so
everybody thanks for your time thanks
for attention of course this is just the
beginning of our of our discussing the
ground so we're looking forward to the
next episode having an announcement go
for it go back god's talk
oh and go back god stuck all right
everybody talk to you soon bye-bye